[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages timeline to see what is
making the headlines with the observer's
chief leader writer sonia soder and the
daily telegraph's chief political
correspondent christopher hope and both
of you with us from now until just
before midnight so welcome to you as
ever then let's turn our attention
festival to the front pages and the
metro describing the testimony of azim
rafiq over his experiences of racism as
revealing poison at the heart of cricket
the game is in a crisis reports the
yorkshire post as it leads with which
players were named in the former
cricketers allegations at the mp's
inquiry
the guardian also has that story but
leads with sleaze allegations it's
revealed a conservative party donor who
supported michael gove's tory leadership
bid had 164 million pounds in government
contracts
to the times now meanwhile boris johnson
faces a confrontation with his back
benchers as he pushes for mps to be
banned from taking on second jobs
church of england's under fire for
helping asylum seekers avoid deportation
by helping convert hundreds of people to
christianity that is the lead story for
the telegraph
wallpaper is coming in all the time but
let's uh discuss those ones first sonia
soda and christopher hope are here and
sonia i think it was the telegraph um
right at the top there that called it
cricket's day of shame um but as we saw
from the yorkshire post too this was
this was a really hard listen wasn't it
it was so hard uh to watch azeem rafiq's
testimony as he talked about some of the
really really shocking outright vile
racist abuse that he received while he
was at yorkshire cricket and i think the
really important thing that came out of
his testimony was first of all the
personal impact that it's had on him and
it's really clear that he feels that he
was not able to achieve his potential
in the game because of the disgusting
racing racist abuse that he faced but i
think the other thing that came out
really strongly was that this this was
not you know just about one or two
individuals engaging in this level of
abuse um there was a a culture of
institutional complicity and he talks
about how some people who he thinks you
know are good people but they just stood
by and let it happen and i you know some
of the terms that he was called the p
word elephant washers it's just really
really disgraceful
and i think another reason why it's so
shocking is we're not talking about
something historic here we're talking
about something that happened really
recently and we're talking about a
complete failure of yorkshire cricket in
its initial response so i think it's
really really shameful i think there are
such serious questions to be asked about
qriket both yorkshire cricket as as a
club but also qriket more broadly and um
you know
he was asked um in his testimony you
know does he think that qriket is
institutionally racist and he said yes
and i think they're really really
serious questions to ask not just about
the individuals involved but the
institutional culture that permits this
completely outrageous level of racist
abuse with with the
terrible toxic impacts that it has on
someone's life
to sort of go on for so long
yes and the the guardian uh leads are on
a different story which we'll come to in
a minute but certainly pictures azeem
rafiq looking very tearful and you know
describing how he was treated after
losing a child which was you know
devastating to listen to but that
question of people standing by
that you know the accusation of how this
was all handled is is at the root of it
too isn't it
yes it was i mean that headline there i
don't want my son to go near it and his
tears and of course the speed was uh
suspended while he was able to uh have a
moment frankly after after breaking down
in tears it's deeply moving and i think
it's a real
one extraordinary wake-up call across
the board for cricket um i've been to a
lot of cricket last year i didn't hear
any racism in the crowd um it was
appeared to be inside these dressing
rooms that we're seeing inside these
cricket clubs which is almost like the
converse thing maybe of of question
marks about football where you have
issues with racism so um i i don't know
what is going on
quite where the ecb has been on this it
seems they've been um unable to act
they're a regulator they can't do
anything about it they can't get
involved
but equally these clubs want advice and
guidance on what to do and yorkshire
just couldn't didn't know what to do
they were frozen by paralysis by what to
do and now we've got this brave guy's
giving evidence i mean it's
extraordinary yeah and the whole issue
of of drinking to
you know the idea that
if you don't drink in a clubhouse you're
not part of the clique and
you know we heard from azeem rafiq that
he had alcohol pulled out poured down
his neck as a 15 year old the idea that
he had to drink to fit in this is these
are all awkward really awkward questions
aren't they sorry christopher
well and and made worse by the fact he's
a muslim man so so we we think was tea
total right so it was not just being
made to drink underage a lot of red wine
but it went to the heart of his faith
right so it's completely offensive um
that was not at yorkshire but it was a
creek club he was uh he was at before
yorkshire i think from the evidence um
but i mean honestly
this is appalling i mean it's not the
help the game needs some help some
support boris johnson in the yorkshire
post by the way the yorkshire post
they're published dealing with it very
straight and and very fair i think and
difficult for them for the county but
boris johnson telling yorkshire post in
torres paper they expect yorkshire and
the ecb to take immediate action
following the brave testimony of mr
rafiq and the entire country will back
that yes indeed so um metro two poison
at the heart of of cricket uh the words
um that you know that he said were used
constantly um deeply offensive uh and
and
you know
really old-fashioned
for for the uk i think so which is what
you said this is this is something that
happened recently
absolutely and i think there's been a
bit of complacency amongst some circles
around racism in the uk
particularly if you look at for example
the government commissioned um sewell
review into anti-racism and and
racial inequality and racial injustice
some of these things have been
underpinned by this idea that actually
outright racism in the uk is completely
a thing of the past and you know
institutional racism just doesn't really
exist and it's people playing the victim
and calling things out as racism which
aren't actually racism i think this
serves as a really serious reminder now
no one would deny that um attitudes have
got a lot better in the uk over the last
40 or 50 years and when you look at sort
of long-scale um data it really does
show that but but what this story
illustrates is that there is outright
racism in some institutions in our
society it has infected cricket a sport
like qriket
and that these institutional cultures
really do exist so what i hope this
story does is challenge this narrative
that actually we've solved racism we've
cracked it and it's not a problem in the
uk anymore because it absolutely is
no one no one's saying that of course
i think i wonder why the cricket has a a
unique issue because it has um people
sitting around for long periods on the
boundary just chatting and talking and
it fosters this kind of phantom
mentality when it just goes too far
completely too far um that was what
appears to be the the the language you
use was so appalling and it seems that
seems to have justified it um maybe some
people in yorkshire but it just doesn't
does it
but i wonder whether the unique way that
qriket
has players
sitting around for long periods that may
foster a kind of casualness about it
which has got to be tackled but whether
he goes further than that into other
institutions well that's a different
match altogether yes well we're
certainly um keeping on what happens uh
after those um very harrowing
allegations uh in the meantime let's
move on to the times tory mps set to
revolt over ban on second jobs this was
the um the u-turn from mr johnson today
ahead of labor's proposals on the very
same matter about what to do about extra
employment for mps uh sonia where are we
so where we are is um so first of all
labour came out today and said that they
were going to put motion to parliament
um tomorrow a binding motion uh that
bans mps engaging in political
consultancy work and this is work you
know there's been such enhanced scrutiny
of this as a result of this big row
about owen patterson and this scandal
about erin patterson whereby owen
patterson egregiously broke the rules on
several occasions essentially doing
things in parliament that were in the
interests of companies that had paid him
so a real a very serious conflict of
interest um and um if this row has just
ticked on because of the way that the
government has handled it if
if parliament had sort of let the motion
go through that um you know owen
patterson had served a 30-day suspension
it just wouldn't have blown up in the
way that it has now um because of the
way the government handled it it tried
to get owen patterson off the hook it
you turned there's been a lot more
scrutiny on the work that other mps have
been doing and unsurprisingly in many
ways given what we know it and i think
it is a minority of mps but it is some
mps engaging in this there are mps that
look like they're in very serious
conflicts of interest and i think this
raises a real question if you're an mp
why are you being paid by a private
business to advise them on their
political strategy it's because you're
an mp and because they hope that they
will get some insider track um on you so
labour came forward and said they were
going to ban political consultancy jobs
um and it seems that boris johnson i
think it's a sign of just how serious
the government feels this is boris
johnson has actually come out and said
no no we're going to do this um now
there's some politicking over apparently
the government's motion is or amendment
to labour's motion is non-binding so it
sounds like labor's motion is is
stronger but this is going to create a
huge divide in the conservative party
now you've got the red wall mps the 2019
intake who are absolutely furious about
the way that the government and boris
johnson handled
erin patterson but you've also got some
tory mps who i think feel quite entitled
to um take work uh where they're paid
for the political lobbying and
strategizing
um and i think that
there's going to be a big backlash from
them christopher just quickly yes
torrey mp is the furious about it this
is all mp he's not tory mp so the
problem is a lot of tory mps do have
other work um i think yes i think
everyone accepts they shouldn't be
lobbyists or pay political consultants
my worry for tory mps is the point the
second point in borussia johnson's
letter to the speaker tonight but today
he said the mps who are prioritizing
outside interest over their constituents
should be investigated now that is an
open season on every mp now for every
journalist to go and challenge these
people and say what are you doing why
are you doing this why that and that's
the problem he's either uncooked for the
tory party and mainly the tory party
less about lobbyists more about what are
you doing why you're not willing for
your voters now he's uncaught a massive
round that'll play out for weeks i think
yeah indeed so yeah we'll have more on
that tomorrow uh pmq's as well and the
liaison committee it's busy enough for
the prime minister without this too is
it not lots more to come as well
including new details emerge concerning
the suspect in the liverpool taxi
explosion we'll talk about that in just
a moment
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now sonia soda and
christopher hope welcome back to both of
you
so to the daily telegraph christopher
this is in connection with but not
concerning uh the liverpool uh explosion
and the suspect there would you could
you just talk us through what this story
is um the suggestion that there are
questions over refugees changing their
religion
to avoid being deported
well we know the suspect in this bombing
was a a christian convert and but with
this is more of a general issue looking
at the issue of thousands of asylum
seekers who have been welcomed to the
anglican faith in recent years and the
telegraph is saying that we have seen
evidence that clergy even provided with
or even be provided with written
guidance on how to navigate the home
office system so it's questions about
whether whether um it's a way of uh by
converting asylum seekers towards
christian faith that has a bearing on
any application to stay in this country
um and that because it's not really
clear in the case of the of this bomber
he had converted to the christian faith
and where he was going with with the
bomb in the taxi we don't know we don't
know enough about this really but
there's questions here about why why
this is a recent convert to christian
faith would they want to do this that
that's the question that they're not
really sure about so there's a we we're
reporting tomorrow tomorrow's telegraph
that peter potel is appalled at what was
described as a merry-go-round of failed
asylum seekers change religion and using
other tactics to try and launch appeal
after appeal so
if you if you can say you become a
christian that maybe may count in your
favor when you go towards uh when you
appeal your your signing application
that was turned down it's not it you
know we're not sure where it's going but
this is a thought yeah sort of an
interesting tangent certainly but um the
suspect in the liverpool case ahmed
al-swelmin
certainly stayed with a christian couple
for some eight months and they were
convinced that he did uh convert to
christianity which is presumably why the
police have been very cautious about a
motive in this incident sonia
absolutely and i think just to sort of
pull it back to the wider story i think
um i'm quite skeptical of the home
office and pretty patel's claims in this
story actually we know that pretty patel
has sort of picked a bit of a culture
war with asylum seekers and um you know
we know she's got an agenda against the
legal profession as well she's attacked
the legal profession for even just
representing asylum seekers which is
really kind of extremely undermining of
our legal system and i think it's
important to say here that the church
has issued a very strong denial at the
end of this story where it says that
there's no evidence um that you know
they've not got any evidence that this
is going on um so i think it is
given that we know the government has an
agenda and the home office and pretty
patel in particular have an agenda
around asylum seekers and looking to
tarnish asylum seekers and
give the impression that a lot of asylum
seekers are here on sort of you know
what they would term bogus claims uh i
think we need to be a bit careful about
these claims coming from the home office
um and look at other evidence
uh very quickly you've got christopher
would you mind if we've got about 30
seconds left uh the the catchly entitled
integrated rail plan is being published
later on this week um and uh fury the
metro tells us about the two lines hs2
and northern powerhouse rail
yes i mean
it's out on thursday so we haven't got
long to wait it's been brief since
sunday and that hasn't really helped the
mood amongst uh northern mps who are
furious about the way this uh the hs2
linked towards
the east of england has been being cut
up but the concern they've got is what
possibly anywhere near leveling up
there's a full cabinet last week on
leveling up leveling up white paper is
coming out before christmas and this
appears to go to the heart of the
problem if you're not going to build
decent rail links what is leveling up
all about